welcome to iOS 17 where you can leave a
FaceTime video message
like this and you can finally set
multiple timers and even make a clone of
your voice Joanna are you really doing
iOS tips again yes yes I am not real
Joanna voice because iOS 17 is here and
there are things that people need to
know
okay so this year isn't really that
dramatic of an overhaul but if you look
closely there are some useful tools
though not too closely because iOS 17
has a new feature that warns you when
you hold your phone too close to your
face
I hope you'll do 17 tips for OS 17. you
get 10 tips and that's it okay fine
maybe I'll do 17.
let's do this
number one contact posters this is my
contact poster it's not really video it
looks like this
this is the screen that will now appear
when you call someone else or exchange
contact information you can design it
however you'd like I'll change it to
a more modern font
and maybe a white you pick up this call
right in the phone app tap contacts then
your name at the top then tap edit in
the upper right then edit again under
your photo then customize to edit your
current one
you pick a main photo or an emoji as the
background and then you can also change
the size font and color of your name you
won't pick it up
nobody picks up the phone anyway
number two name drop
want to share contact info stop texting
your information and start bumping
phones together
jern and Joanna Stern
definitely not the same people
when two phones running iOS 17 are
brought near each other you'll see this
trippy effect
top share and well that's what happens
similar to airdrop name drop needs
bluetooth enabled you can also use the
feature to wirelessly share photos or
websites
it's super cool when it works
nope this keeps happening
do something
you love each other I just want to give
credit Android has had this sort of
feature since around 2017.
okay I feel better now that I've said
that let's move on number three FaceTime
video messages
sometimes when your friend or Alter Ego
doesn't pick up you just want to leave a
FaceTime message after ringing for a
while you'll see the record video button
press it and you'll get a countdown
timer before you have to leave your
taste Joanna it's Joanna just calling to
say hi hope you're having a good day
call me back bye
when you're done recording you can hit
the retake button to re-record or hit
the Green Arrow to send it off and send
I hope she likes it oh
the receiver can play the message in the
FaceTime app
number four live voicemail time for
Grandma Joanna's old Tech lesson
this is an answering machine when
somebody called you you could hear the
message out loud in real time and if you
wanted you could pick up the call in the
middle of the message it was called call
screening and now it's back
kinda
when someone leaves you a voicemail now
like my mom here you can see a live
transcription of the caller's message
and you can pick up in the middle
can you just give me a call back when
you get this hello
you called me back already no this is a
new feature where I can pick up in the
middle of your message
yes I'm going to screen your calls
great
live voicemail is on by default in iOS
17. you can deactivate it by going to
settings phone live voicemail number
five standby mode speaking of old school
standby mode can turn your phone into
basically a fancy alarm clock
this is best if you have a nice magsafe
charging stand like this 100 Belkin
boost charge Pro but really you just
have to make sure your iPhone is locked
horizontal not laying on a flat surface
and charging swipe horizontally to
choose between a widget screen a photo
screen and a clock screen in each of
those three modes you can swipe
vertically to pick other options and you
can hold down on the screen for even
more customization
there's also this cool night mode where
your display auto adapts to low light
with this red tin
number six Duncan autocorrect yes in iOS
17 if you type a certain profanity that
rhymes with the word duck it will no
longer auto correct to duck
yeah plus when autocorrect changes a
word a bluish Gray Line will show
underneath tap it and it will show the
original word you typed if you want to
choose that instead and as you're typing
some word suggestions May pop up in Gray
tap on the space bar to insert them
number seven screen distance
holding your phone too close to your
face can be bad for your eyes Apple
suggests keeping the screen at least 12
inches away but instead of doing this
this is how we should all be walking
around you can enable screen distance
which warns you if your phone is too
close it won't let you use the phone
until you've backed it up to the right
distance to enable it go to settings
screen time screen distance and turn it
on this is a great feature for some
people
on the other hand I kept getting these
number eight personal voice this is
primarily an accessibility feature for
those that are at risk of losing their
ability to speak to create a synthesized
version of your voice go to settings
accessibility then personal voice and
you'll be asked to record your voice by
reading 150 randomized text prompts
it's so nice to see you again
are you on your way
just letting you know we're only at 30.
[Music]
yes 75 halfway there
these findings led to the creation of
the radio and other devices a hundred
and fifty
after that the phone needs to be plugged
in and locked so it can process the info
so basically it needs to happen
overnight when it's done enable live
speech in settings triple-click the side
button and type in whatever you'd like
to be said out loud
this is me Joanna Joanna Joanna it's not
great
but it there's some hints of me in there
worried about someone stealing your
voice well Apple has built in some
important privacy features here it uses
on-device machine learning so it isn't
sent to Apple servers plus you need to
use face ID to create this feature or
log in to access it number nine custom
stickers hold down on the subject in a
photo watch for the shimmering outline
then select add sticker it will
automatically save to your stickers
drawer then you can select add effect to
add some different styles to it and if
it's a live photo it does a little
animation now when you're in a message
you can send that sticker number 10
check-in messages
iOS can now automatically text someone
when you get to a destination so people
don't worry if you forgot to do it
yourself let's see if my phone checks in
with this phone when I get to New York
Penn Station
on my phone I went to messages and
tapped the plus button then more and
then check in it automatically defaults
to your home location press edit and
type in another location
then I selected my mode of
transportation and sent the message to
stowanna's phone
about 15 minutes later when I arrived at
Penn Station my phone automatically sent
a message to stoana saying I had arrived
both phones do have to be running iOS 17
and you can adjust how much location and
other information you share with your
contact oh are you still watching
let's do some more tips bonus round
two-factor verification texts and emails
can automatically be deleted by going to
settings passwords password options
clean up automatically in Safari tap the
A's in the bottom left and select listen
to page
let's all start leaving voicemails again
you can now also download maps in Apple
Maps so you can access them offline oh
and you can right swipe on a specific
message to reply to it in the find my
app you can now share the location of an
air tag with another person you can
finally set multiple timers in the clock
app or by asking Siri how many timers do
you have set there are three timers this
is the future we were promised and you
no longer need to say hey in hey Siri
Siri
is this some sort of sick joke
okay I found this on the web for is
there some sort of sick joke okay thank
you Siri Okay Siri enough
oh and you can snap a photo of your
laundry tag then tap the i in the photos
app to finally learn what those symbols
actually mean
we did it 17 tips for iOS 17. I will see
you back here in 83 years for 100 tips
for iOS 100. Siri will you be here for
me in iOS 100
[Music]
I found this on the web
all right Siri
[Music]